[Music]
[Applause]
very exciting day after the Super Bowl
so the game is where did Troy Aikman
watch the Super Bowl yesterday and we
have no knowledge I'd like to go first
okay
I bet Troy hosted a small get-together
but like maybe like a local restaurant
ran out of room he doesn't want a bunch
of Riff Raff messing up his knife but do
you have to have a football like a
Wonderlic test before you get into
Troy's party so he doesn't have to
answer stupid questions great idea okay
I'm gonna go local restaurant he hosted
okay fritzy
uh I think somewhere in Dallas maybe a
big sports bar or something no that
wouldn't happen yes uh Seaton I think
Troy went to the game okay how do you
use there oh I don't think he went uh
Mark alone in his house alone in his
house okay
um I'm gonna say
with family at
maybe in uh Cabo how about that maybe
he's with Joe Buck in Cabo
let's bring in Troy Aikman who's playing
the Troy Aikman game Troy where did you
watch the game
I uh I watched it in Santa Barbara I've
got a place here watched it with some
friends so I typically a little bit of
uh some accuracy on all year olds Parts
uh I usually have a party back at my
place in Dallas uh invite a bunch of
people over but I did not did not do
that this year but I got a chance to
actually sit and watch the game uh so it
was good but do people bother you when
you host a party
no no I no if I thought they would I
wouldn't invite them to the party okay
do you like that uh idea of a Wonderlic
test to get into a Troy Aikman party
yeah I hadn't heard it put quite like
that but I I do like that Dan that's uh
that's good it's genius on your part
that's gonna start happening next year I
like that uh joining us on behalf of uh
eight Elite light uh beer and uh A lot's
happened with this uh logger that you uh
brought to the marketplace certainly in
the state of Texas
yeah we've uh we've just had our one
year anniversary so you know you were a
part of it of course when I came on the
show last year at the Super Bowl and
talked about it and and hoping that it
would be received the way that we hope
that it might
and it has been so uh We've surpassed
all of our expectations it's been very
well received uh obviously as you know
it's a it's a light logger 90 calories
2.6 carb people for people that are
active and now we're looking at moving
it into to other markets uh and we're
excited about that so year two as is
always the case we're not the new kid on
the Block anymore and uh we've got a lot
of work left ahead of us
somebody sent me a six pack of your beer
a couple of weeks ago
do you know I'm hoping you don't still
have uh five left Dan no but but I there
was there was six a six pack on my
doorstep here at the man cave good but
good I don't know who sent it well we
sent it yeah oh well thank you all right
you're welcome well we polished it off
that day they're good oh yeah yeah but I
was like you left kittens on a doorstep
and I'm like oh I got I gotta send a
12-pack next time okay
[Laughter]
um what were you thinking at halftime
last night
uh well I mean I I don't
depends on how you're looking at it from
whose perspective what I what I thought
was that a lot of really good things
have had happened for Philadelphia and I
also knew as was the conversation
throughout the last couple of weeks that
with Patrick Mahomes there's not a lead
that's really you know that
insurmountable we had them when they
played against the 49ers we called that
game Joe and I did so we certainly
understand it
um the the looking at the game Dan the
thing that I was most impressed with
sitting there watching it was just how
good Kansas City's offensive line was I
I just didn't feel like at any point now
there were some times you know my homes
had to move around and but that's that's
every week every quarterback but I
thought for a wanted pass rush like like
Philadelphia had to not come away with a
sack and really not impact that game I I
thought that was the real key uh in the
Chiefs being able to win the game
there were a couple of moments we'll get
to the uh the holding penalty but there
were a couple of moments where I thought
the Eagles defense was really confused
by a couple of different sets that the
Chiefs had yeah now had they shown any
of those sets previous to this game in
your opinion you're talking about in The
Red Zone yeah yeah I didn't think that I
I didn't think what they did on those
plays Dan I I they weren't
they weren't that challenging I mean
those are those are staple plays down in
the Red Zone where you start a guy like
you're gonna you know Jet Sweep them
across or he's going to drag across the
field he comes out of it they're they're
they're they're good calls they're
expecting man coverage that's what they
get and the Eagles didn't didn't play it
very well you know and a lot of that is
simply that's where the speed of the
Chiefs comes in uh because those guys
are so fast that in order to be able to
keep up with them down there when you're
trying to run with them across the field
you kind of got to get a head start on
them so that's why they get out ahead
well then they pivot and they come back
out of it twice uh and for easy
touchdown so the other part of that of
course was the Red Zone efficiency of
Kansas City I mean they just they came
away with touchdowns once they got down
there
um Mahomes in the second half
what was he seeing that made it so much
simpler than the first half well I think
what happens especially in a big game it
happens every week but but especially
when you get into a game like the Super
Bowl and granted even though Mahomes has
played
in Prior Super Bowls it's still a little
bit of a different animal so I think
that they're when you start the game
things are going pretty fast uh you
don't always see things as clearly and
then as the game goes along it slows
down and it becomes much like any other
game at that point and I felt that in
the second half
you know not that he struggled that much
in the first half I thought he was
pretty good throughout but I just felt
that he was seeing the field really well
uh was getting time to throw more
importantly and then the other part of
it as well is I thought
you know my thoughts on Kansas City
going into the game was you knew what
Philadelphia wanted to do and they
wanted to run the ball you know what
Kansas City likes to do and they like to
throw the ball and why wouldn't they
when Mahomes is their quarterback but
I've seen them when they've run the ball
and they've been highly successful and I
was wondering if if Andy Reed would be
willing to stick with that and he was I
thought they had to be balanced to take
the pressure off this offensive line and
I thought I thought it was just a
textbook uh offensive game plan and the
way that he called it throughout that
game last night talking to Troy Aikman
Jalen hurts uh aside from the fumble
those are some big time plays in the
biggest game in your life what did you
think big time plays uh Dallas Goddard
made some amazing catches in that game
uh I thought you know Kansas City or
excuse me Philadelphia has has nothing
to be ashamed of that's the
disappointing thing when you get into
the Super Bowl and you and you lose but
I will say this that
and I'd said it during the week on
another show that I was on and I think
it's really true Jimmy Johnson would
always say to us before these games it's
not who makes the most big plays it's
who makes the fewest bad plays when
you're talking about big games
and when you look at this game and I
really felt that that would be the story
I it you know everybody talks about the
plays this guy can make or that that guy
can make and so many times it's who
makes the fewest bad plays and and that
bad play by Jalen hurts obviously ended
up being the difference in the score
yeah because I thought if it they were
it felt like they should have been up
more than 10. I agree you know I agree
they had they had dominated the first
half in a lot of ways and and didn't
fully take advantage of that and and
when you're playing against good teams
especially good teams quarterback uh by
one of the real greats uh those things
come back to haunt you all right let's
get to the holding call that was called
on James Bradberry we've had athletes
who've joined us current former and you
guys just want a consistent game cult
like you know what what's going to be
called and what's not going to be called
and then that one kind of came out of
Nova there were no holding calls in that
game and then all of a sudden we have
that uh do you have any problem with
that call
uh well
it was interesting because when when
when Fox replayed it and then Mike
Pereira got on initially when they when
they replayed it I didn't think they
went to the start of really kind of
where the hole that was called took
place so I agreed with Mike saying hey
if you go back and you show it sooner in
the route
and then they showed it and I just
didn't see I didn't see what I thought I
saw initially now I will say I don't I
don't think and and I don't think there
was a great look at it I think there was
one angle I didn't I didn't see a good
good look at a at a real hole for that
moment in the game so I I personally
didn't like the call I don't know though
Dan if you say hey you can't make that
call at that point in the game I I I
don't know that I agree with with that
premise because I think holding is
holding and that's what the official's
job is you have to be willing to make a
call if in fact it happened but from
what I could tell and what I saw I
didn't think there was enough there
for to basically give this not give but
to basically hand the Super Bowl over to
Kansas City the game was over at that
point I I didn't feel like there was it
to me it had to be pretty egregious to
where there was just no doubt and I
think the fact that we're sitting here
having this conversation and I'm sure
people are all across the country
probably tells you there wasn't quite
enough there yeah Dean blandino uh Fox's
uh rules analyst going to join us here
coming up a little bit uh also the
longer halftime show it seemed like that
would have benefited Mahomes who had the
you know the tender ankle and that must
feel interminable when you're just
sitting there and did you get to hear
the music at all did you care who the
halftime show was in your super bowls
and no I could care couldn't care less
uh you know and and I probably my first
Super Bowl uh was probably the best
halftime show in the history of Super
Bowls and that was Michael Jackson
um and I I didn't I I all I wanted to do
was win a Super Bowl day and I know what
that meant I know what that meant to a
quarterback now Michael Irvin on the
other hand he says that he went out and
snuck out there to where he could watch
the halftime show and I'm and I don't I
don't remember that but I'm not at all
surprised by that you know that would be
expected if you had input on the Cowboys
in the off season
let's say one or two things that you
said to Jerry Jones you got to do this
or stand Pat whatever it is what would
you say yeah I think they've got a I
don't think they
I don't think they addressed the wide
receiver position when Amari Cooper left
uh I I've always said Dan back when back
when I was playing that your your
offense is only as good as your third
receiver
and now I would say that that might very
well be you're only as good as your
fourth receiver and it doesn't have to
be a wide receiver it could be a tight
end or but you you've got to have four
pretty solid weapons in today's game if
you're gonna be the offense that you
really need to be to move the football
and so they move they lose Amari Cooper
Michael Gallup was was coming off a
major knee injury you know he wasn't the
same guy that we had seen from him the
the workload really came down to cd-lam
so I I believe that they will they tried
to when they brought in Ty Hilton there
was talk about Odell Beckham they
recognized I think throughout the year
where they were limited and and now I
think if the running back they're gonna
have to make some hard decisions in
addition to that to players that have
been impactful for them and do they keep
them guys for instance uh like Zeke
Elliott you know what's going to happen
with him
Wright Thompson did a wonderful profile
on Joe Montana during Super Bowl week
and Joe was forever the greatest
quarterback of all time
and then Tom Brady blew by him and
Wright Thompson pointed out that Joe
kind of struggling with that like you
lose your identity as the greatest
quarterback of all time as we see you
know the game get farther and farther
away from guys like you who have played
like do you ever worry about your place
your Hall of Famer but do you ever worry
about like where you are in history
well I would say this Dan that for uh
I've got that article I haven't yet read
it I've heard it's fantastic so I'm
excited really excited about reading it
I I also Joe Montana was in the league
when I came into the league I watched
him when I was in high school in college
I've always felt for the longest time
that he was the greatest to have ever
done it and then you lose sight of guys
like Otto Graham and those type players
that we just didn't get a chance to see
and then I called the game when Tom
Brady won his fifth Super Bowl and I
said at that time I I don't think we can
dispute it now this is the greatest
that's ever done and then he's gone on a
course and then really solidified that
opinion
am I worried Dan I no one's ever thought
I was the greatest so this is real easy
for me this is you know I don't it's
never been that important to me on where
I've placed uh in in the list of great
quarterbacks I I'm proud of my career I
I went into the Hall of Fame I I joined
the Cowboys I was drafted by the Cowboys
to win Super Bowls I was able to win
three of them and at the end of the day
that's all that matters I mean in my
opinion that's all that matters because
that's why we play and that's why we
were drafted and that's why we get paid
is to go win championships and I was
able to win three of them and and that
Stacks up pretty good in in the history
of quarterbacks but beyond that uh if
somebody says hey you know you don't
deserve this or you're you weren't I I
don't really care I'm I'm broadcasting
you know I'm broadcasting games I'm not
the guy who really wants to sit back and
talk about 25 years ago it's just never
been really my my thing and people say
really well why is that and I said well
you know it'd almost be like if if every
person who's listening to this if they
were told you know hey let's go back and
talk about your Junior High days and
what those meant to you and you say man
they were they were fun times but you
know I've kind of moved on from then and
so that's where I'm at I don't pay a lot
of attention to to all that I I admire
the great quarterbacks and the people
that are doing it where I'm at and all
of that uh is really pretty irrelevant
you've got one quarterback to win one
game and you can't pick you
I would uh
uh well it's a great question I I would
say I would either take Joe Montana I'd
probably take Joe Montana I think Tom
Brady would be a close second but my I I
saw Joe do things of course I we've all
seen Tom do it as well I one of those
two guys I'd probably go with Joe
it's great to uh talk to you again and
good luck with the beer it's uh called
Eight Elite light blogger and uh it's
Troy Aikman done an incredible job the
first year and starting to Branch out uh
building the fastest independent beer
ever launched in the state of Texas Troy
uh great to talk you have a great off
season thank you Dan always a pleasure
that's uh T-Roy Aikman